The add and remove methods, let's you add elements or remove them at arbitrary
index positions. So if we add a bunch of pictures and now we add one at
position 0, the new one gets added here and what used to be position 0 is now
position one. What used to be position one is now position two and so on. Now
let's look at remove, here we remove the element at position two. And the other
offsets of course, are now different. Note that you've seen a different version
of the add method when we first learned about array lists. That method did not
have a position, when you omit the position, then add simply adds it at the end
of the array list. In the next exercise I'd like you to put add and remove to
work. Here's what I want you to do. When you have an array list of pictures, I
want you to slide the last one to the front so that all the others get shifted
to the right. Go ahead and give it a try.